- On passe notre panel
municipal. Vous venez d'entendre
Monsieur Camara, j'aimerais
entendre votre réaction à cette
entrevue.
- Je suis content de le voir
dans son visage, on voit ses
traits, on se rappelle de ce
quand il était au palais de
justice, je suis soulagé que ce
dossier lassera enfin régler
pour ce qui s'est passé. C'était
une erreur évidemment mais il
s'est passé plein de choses
Sorella et je le sens comme
immigrant, quelqu'un se fait
arrêter par la police déjà c'est
quelque chose qu'o.
Mais en plus, tout ce qu'il a
subi lui, de faire sortir du
véhicule par la fenêtre, et tout
ça, cette soirée-là, on ne
pourra pas comprendre tout ce
qui s'est passé mais il ne s'est
passé beaucoup de choses qui
n'auraie se passent
normalement. Ça été faite vite,
évidemment parce qu'il y a un
policier qui était à terre, on
ne sait pas ce qui s'est passé,
celle qui était la c'était
Mamadi Ca Mamadi Ca Mamadi Ca a
voiture, tout se passe vite
évidemment. Le problème c'est
aurait pas dû passer
séjour en prison.
ne ne veut vivre ce
qu'il a vécu mais il faut dire
qu'à partir de ce moment-là,
après l'emprisonnement, il faut
reconnaître que tout s'est bien
passé. La police de Montréal est
revenue chercher des preuves, à
trouver la caméra du ministère
des transports a pu identifi
que ce n'était pas lui, il a été
libéré, on a fini par arrêter la
personne qui a commis le crime,
et donc pour lui, personne ne
veut passer par là mais après ça
la société a bien fonctionnée.
- Est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas
évité tous ces dérapages il
n'avait pas eu des
corporelles? La ville s'est
engagée 'est
pas concrétisé.
- Le caméra aurait peut-être pu
changer les choses mais ça
dépend parce que là il y avait
un policier, si les autres
policiers avaient été là, on
aurait pu avoir différents
angles de vue. Parce que la le
policier est tombé par terre.
Est-ce qu'on aurait pu en voir
plus? Effectivement les caméras
vont nous permettre de redonner
confiance dans le système dans
la façon que ça fonctionne parct
maintenant de: est-ce qu'il a
fait est-ce qu'il ne l'a pas
fait? Les caméras vont permettre
de redonner confiance de la
population. Parce
qu'actuellement les gens filent
beaucoup avec leurs caméras mais
on ajuste un côté de la
médaille, on n'a pas l'autre
version. Le fait d'avoir la
vérité c'est important. L'époque
j'étais là, on avait fait
projet pilote l'avion avait des
commentaires des gens qui
disaient: à partir du moment où
le policier alluma
les gens étaient tranquilles. On
a toujours de versontontontontot
différen
encore, ça va dédramatiser
beaucoup d'événements qui se
passent. Souvent nouvelle des
bâtons va
faire quoi, c'est quoi la loi,
etc.
- Salaire compliqué, même
Camara dit
que il y a deux sortes d'enjeux
par rapport aux informations
personnelles. Luc qu'en pensez-
vous?
- Je suis pour, vraiment ça
coûte 20 millions de dollars, il
faut l'implanter en étant sur ce
qu'on veut faire et des
résultats attendus. Il n'y a pas
simplement la caméra elle-même,
il faut que les images
enregistrées par la caméra
soient archivées, il y a tout un
processus pour avoir accès aux
images pour protéger les
informations personnelles. Alors
il y a une hiérarchie pour avoir
accès aux images, il faut
beaucoup de monde pour gérer,
mais là où il y a un gain, ce
n'est pas dans le arrestation
comme Monsieur Camara, le
policier comme l'a dit Annie, a
été attaqué par derrière et il
est tombé. Des fois ce n'est pas
le cas comme celui-là, mais
comme il y a des prises à bras-
le-corps et que la caméra
n'arrive pas à filmer. Mais
lorsqu'il y a une intervention
où la caméra est ouvert, le
policier et les prévenus savent
que la caméra est filmée. Ça
aurait très bien passé la à
Québec, ou le jeune ont filmé
des policiers qui ont procédé à
une arrestation. Ça permet aux
policiers de documenter leurs
preuves et ça permet aussi aux
citoyens de documenter la leur.
- Vous êtes donc tous les deux
en faveur, reste à voir ce que
la ville fera. Parler des
policiers, vous en pensez quoi
des affaires d'écusson avec une
petite ligne bleue, sur certains
uniformes des policiers. Des
gens disent que c'est à
l'honneur des gens qui ont été
blessés à l'honneur des gens qui
ont été blessés. D'autres disent
que ça a une connotation
beaucoup plus douteuse. Vous en
pensez quoi.
- J'ai fait quelques petites
recherches là-dessus, je me suis
posé des questions avant les
réactions de tout le monde, il
faut se rappeler pourquoi ça
avait été fait. Ce n'est pas
Montréal, ce n'est pas Canada,
c'est mondial. En 1950, en
Grande-Bretagne, c'était une
écusson qui était noir, avec une
ligne bleue entre les deux. Il
disait Lenoir en haut le bleu
c'est la police et embrasser les
méchants. Donc la police est là
pour balancer le : et s'assurer
que... on entend parler que des
gens se sont appropriés de ça,
et qu'il faut l'enlever. La loi
dit qu'on ne peut pas toujours
mettre des choses sur nos
uniformes, les une forme de
police, la loi de police est
claire là-dessus, cependant il y
a des endroits où c'est toléré.
Là actuellement, c'est est-ce
que l'emprunt ou on enlève? Il
faut se rappeler pourquoi ça été
mis en place. C'est justement
pour les policiers qui ont été
morts en service et pour le
policier c'est l'occasion de se
souvenir de leur policier.
- C'est le danger avec les
symboles, surtout quand les
années passent. Vous nous parlez
de 1950, le seul ennui ce qu'il
peut y avoir de la récupération.
- D'acclamer à deux aux États-
Unis.
- Un message fort douteux
absolument, il y a vraiment eu
des gens qui ont expliqué la vie
des noirs est important mais la
vie des policiers aussi. À
partir du moment ça été récupéré
par un mouvement de droite dont
les intentions sont pas claires,
on ne peut plus faire semblant
que c'est banal. Il est trop
tard maintenant parce que c'est
banal, c'est peut-être une
volonté d'exprimer la mission de
la police, la liberté de
représenter la police et comme
ça été récupéré il faut enlever
ces élections.
- Donc vous êtes contre ça.
- Oui.
- Là-dessus j'ajouterai peut-
être un parallèle je trouve ça
dommage de retirer ça car ça été
mal utilisé. Il y a une gang de
rue dans Saint-Michel qui
s'appelle les 67, il s'appelle
comme ça à cause de la ligne
d'autobus. Il faudrait dire
quoi, qu'il faut changer le
numéro d'autobus? Ce n'est pas
blanc, ce n'est pas noir, c'est
entre les deux mais la raisons
pour laquelle ç'avait été fait
initialement c'est justement
pour permettre aux policiers...
- est-ce que la ville devrait
trancher?
- La décision qu'elle a pris et
très sage, c'est-à-dire délaissé
à la police le soin de citer,
donc laissons la police prendre
une décision là-d